AND I AM KIM BRUNHUBER, THIS IS
CNN NEWSROOM.
THE U.S. AND SOUTH KOREA SAID
THAT THEY BEGIN JOINT NAVAL
EXERCISES ON THE EAST COAST OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA, JOINT
DRILLS BETWEEN THE U.S., SOUTH
KOREA, AND JAPAN HAVE BEEN
ONGOING SINCE LAST WEEK BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS,
PRIVATELY ADMIT TO CNN THAT
THEY LACK HARD INTELLIGENCE,
AND WANT TO KNOW WHY NORTH
KOREA SUDDENLY STEPPED UP ITS
PROVOCATIONS WITH A FLURRY OF
BALLISTIC MISSILE TESTS.
THEY SAY, NORTH KOREA'S INNER
WORKINGS ARE ROUNDING IN
SECRECY.
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO PREDICT
WHAT LEADER, KIM JONG-UN WOULD
DO NEXT.
BUT, IT IS WIDELY BELIEVED THAT
NORTH KOREA IS ON THE VERGE OF
CARRYING OUT ITS SEVENTH
UNDERGROUND NUCLEAR TEST.
CNN'S PAULA HANCOCKS IS
FOLLOWING ALL OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS FOR US FROM SEOUL.
SOUTH KOREA.
SO, PAULA, TENSIONS SEEM TO BE
RISING.
TAKE US THROUGH WHAT IS BEHIND,
US AND THE RESPONSE FROM THE
U.S. AND ITS ALLIES.
>> WELCOME, IT IS INTERESTING
THAT SENIOR ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
MATTER DO TELL CNN THAT THERE
IS A LACK OF HARD INTELLIGENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO NORTH KOREA.
NOW IT IS SOMETHING THAT I
DON'T THINK WILL SURPRISE MANY,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT IS SUCH
CLOSED OFF COUNTRY.
BUT IT ALSO ILLUMINATING THAT
IT'S EVEN FOR THE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, THE VERY
DIFFICULT TO TRY AND GUESS WHAT
KIM JOHNSON THE NORTH KOREAN
LEADER IS GOING TO DO NEXT.
FOR EXAMPLE, DO NOTES THAT THEY
BELIEVE, THAT HE IS READY FOR A
SEVENTH GRAND NUCLEAR TEST.
THAT'S AN IDEA.
THAT'S IT SHARED HERE IN SEOUL,
AS, WELL AMONG THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
BUT WHAT THEY BELIEVE NOW IS
THE POLITICAL WILL IS YET TO BE
THERE AND THEY SIMPLY DON'T
KNOW WHEN KIM JONG-UN MAY
DECIDE TO DO IT.
SO CERTAINLY IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT NORTH KOREA IS
CARRYING OUT QUITE SO MANY
MISSILE TESTS AT THE MOMENT.
THEY CARRIED OUT SIX LAUNCHES
IN JUST 12 DAYS.
FOR NORTH KOREA'S POINT OF VIEW,
THEY HAVE SAID, THROUGH THE
FOREIGN MINISTRY, AND STAGE ONE
MERIDA, THAT THEY ARE CARRYING
OUT THESE LAUNCHES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN JOINT DRILLS BETWEEN
THE U.S. AND SOUTH KOREA.
BLAMING THE UNITED STATES.
BLAMING THE TENSIONS ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
NOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED AT THIS
POINT WE KNOW IS THAT THERE IS
THIS TWO-DAY NAVAL DRILL AS YOU
MENTIONED.
THIS IS BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREA.
THE U.S. S ONE RONALD REAGAN
BACK IN THE WATERS IN THE EAST
COAST OF SOUTH KOREA, BEING
PART OF THIS NAVAL DRILL.
AND JUST YESTERDAY, ON THURSDAY,
THERE WAS A TRILATERAL DRILL
INVOLVING THE JAPANESE NAVY AS
WELL.
AND ALL THREE HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS IN RESPONSE
TO WHAT THEY ARE SEEING FROM
NORTH KOREA.
TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE
MILITARILY CAPABLE OF
RESPONDING TO ANY THREAT THAT
NORTH KOREA COULD PROVIDE.
BUT OF COURSE, THESE NAVAL
DRILLS ARE WHAT PYONGYANG HAS
SAID THAT IT WAS THE REASON FOR
THEIR MISSILE LAUNCHES AT THE
BEGINNING, SO EXPERTS ARE
EXPECTING THIS-FOR-TAT TO
CONTINUE.
KIM?
>> ALL RIGHT, PAULA HANCOCKS,
IN SEOUL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN A SHORT TIME AGO, I SPOKE
WITH INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS
EXPERT, DANIEL KINGSTON, IN
SEOUL FOR HIS, TAKE ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THERE'S BEEN A LONG
DEVELOPMENT PLAN, THE PARTY
CONGRESS, OF JANUARY OUT LAST
YEAR --
KIM ANNOUNCED THAT WISH LIST,
BUT THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THESE CAPABILITIES FOR DECADES.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT
TO ACQUIRE AND HAVE IN THEIR
TOOL KIT TO PUSH THEIR
POLITICAL AGENDA.
AND NOW WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
SOME PUSHBACK.
AND INTERNATIONAL SECURITY
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE U.S.
AND SOUTH KOREA AND JAPAN AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NORTH
KOREA WOULD LIKE TO PREVENT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO PREVENT ANY
INTERVENTION IN THE KOREAN
PENINSULA IN CASE OF ANY KIND
OF CONTINGENCY.
BUT THESE TYPES OF MISSILE
EXERCISES AND IF THEY HAD AN
AIR GROUND ATTACK EXERCISE,
THIS COULD NOT COMPEL OR COURSE
THE SOUTH KOREANS, THE AMERICAN,
AND THE JAPANESE, FROM SEIZING
THIS INTERNATIONAL SECURITY
COOPERATION.
>> YEAH, I MEAN IS THE SAME
SORT OF IRONIC CONSEQUENCES OF
PUTIN IN NOT WANTING NATO
SOLIDARITY, AND HIS INVASION OF
UKRAINE, RESULTING IN EXACTLY
THAT.
SO IN TERMS OF THE WESTERN
RESPONSE, WE'VE BEEN SEEING
THIS PATTERN FOR 30 YEARS.
YOU KNOW, NORTH KOREA RIVAL
FALL OF U.S. AND ITS ALLIES.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO DO MUCH HERE.
>> RIGHT, SO IN MY VIEW, THE
NEUTRAL DETERRENCE IS ROBUST.
IT'S NO ONE'S INTEREST TO
ENGAGE IN A CONFLICT.
THE DIFFERENT PARTIES IN THE
REGION WILL TRY TO PUSH THEIR
POLITICAL OBJECTIVES, AND TRY
TO ACHIEVE GOALS.
SO FOR NORTH KOREA, THAT'S
GETTING OUT OF THE SANCTIONS
REGIME.
LIFTING UN SANCTIONS AND
MULTILATERAL SANCTIONS.
AGAINST THE REGIME, FOR THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAM, AND THEIR
MISSILE PROGRAM.
THEY WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE
TERMINATION OF THE U.S.
MILITARY DEPLOYMENTS AND
SECURITY TREATIES IN THE
REGION.
AND OF COURSE THEY WOULD LIKE
TO BE RECOGNIZED AS A PURE
NUCLEAR WEAPON STATES, AND ALL
THAT THEY BELIEVED CRUDE FROM
THAT STATUS.
SO THESE ARE THE TYPE OF GOALS
ULTIMATELY RESULTING IN SOME
KIND OF KOREAN CONFEDERATION,
OR UNIFICATION OF KOREA ON
NORTH KOREAN TERMS.
SO THEY'VE HAD THIS WISH LIST
THAT HAS BEEN VERY CONSISTENT
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THESE TYPES
OF WEAPON SYSTEMS AND THIS
POWER, THIS MILITARY CAPABILITY,
CAN HELP ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
BUT NOW WE ARE SEEING THE
BALANCE AND BLOW BACK AGAINST
THEIR DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
AND I THINK THAT WILL PROBABLY
CONTINUE.
FORTUNATELY IT'S A SABLE, BUT
WE CAN ALWAYS HAVE AN ACCIDENT.
>> YEAH, LET ME JUST JUMP IN.
I MEAN PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
OPPORTUNE A GO SHEET WITHOUT
PRECONDITIONS, ANYTIME, ANY
PLACE, AS HE HAS SAID, WHY
HASN'T NORTH KOREA ACCEPTED?
WHY HAS THERE JUST BEEN JUST
BEEN SILENCE?
>> WELL I THINK BECAUSE THERE
IS NO CONVERGENCE OF ENTRANCE.
OR ANYTHING ON THE TABLE THAT
WOULD LEAD TO A MUTUALLY
ACCEPTABLE AGREEMENT.
SO THE THINGS THAT THE U.S.
WOULD LIKE TO ACHIEVE SOME KIND
OF ARMS CONTROL AGREEMENTS, A
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH
KOREA.
THAT IS OFF THE TABLE FOR NORTH
ANY TYPE OF YOU KNOW STATUS
FROM A SUMMIT MEETING OR THE
SYMBOLISM OF THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN ACHIEVED UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
SO THERE'S REALLY NOTHING TO
TALK ABOUT OTHER THAN SOME KIND
OF YOU KNOW ESTABLISHMENT OF
HOTLINES AND COMMUNICATION
CHANNELS TO AVOID A KIND OF
ACCIDENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE HAD --
A >> YEAH --
LET ME JUMP IN --
YOU ARE --
WHY A DENUCLEARIZATION IS JUST
NOT A --
IS A NO GO FOR NORTH KOREA.
EXPLAIN WHY THAT IS FOR US?
>> WELL --
WE CAN DO A WHOLE SEMINAR, A
WHOLE SEMESTER ON THAT TOPIC.
[LAUGHS]
BUT TO BE VERY BRIEF, THE
HISTORY OF THE NORTH KOREANS
NORTH KOREAN REGIME, THE KIM
FAMILY REGAIN.
KOREAN WORKERS PARTY.
IT'S PART OF THEIR WORLDVIEW.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE ONLY
PATHWAY TO SECURITY IS THROUGH
MATERIAL CAPABILITIES, FORCE.
THAT'S HOW YOU RISE TO THE TOP
OF POLITICAL SYSTEM IN NORTH
KOREA.
SO EXCHANGING MILITARY
CAPABILITIES INCLUDING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN THE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
CONTRADICTS ANYTHING THEY THINK
ABOUT FOR THE INSTRUMENTS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR SECURITY AND
SURVIVING THE INTERNATIONAL
SYSTEM.
THEY LOOK AT THE SYSTEM AS
BEING MEDICINE, EVERYONE IS OUT
TO GET NORTH KOREA.
YOU MIGHT CALL IT PARANOID.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD CALL IT
PARANOID.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY BELIEVE,
AND TO EXCHANGE, THAT ANY KIND
OF SECURITY GUARANTEES, SOME
KIND OF COLLECTIVE SECURITY
SYSTEM, CONTRADICTS EVERYTHING
THAT THEY BELIEVE THEN.
SO UNLESS THERE IS SOME CHANGE
AND THINKING ABOUT THE REGIME,
IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> YEAH.
UNLESS THEY GET MORE PRESSURE
FROM THEIR ALLIES, YOU KNOW
CHINA, AND RUSSIA, WHICH
DOESN'T SEEM LIKELY RIGHT NOW
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY IN THE UN.
WE'LL HAVE TO LEAVE